hi there Steve Kaufman here and today
I'm going to talk about starting
languages from scratch and I'm going to
do a little experiment
uh gonna play with some languages
starting some languages from scratch
showing you how I do it on link of
course and I'm also going to show you
here as I sit by my computer and what I
do and show you what it looks like so
without further Ado you should be seeing
my page here where normally I'm in
Persian
but for the purpose of this exercise
I'm going to look at what other
languages there are that I could be
doing
is so I go down the list here you'll see
that I don't have many known words in
English because I don't learn English
here I've played around with it German
has quite a bunch I didn't do Japanese
here Russia 93 000 Wars
but let's go to the zero ones now Dutch
I could play with Dutch the trouble is
it's too easy because a lot of the words
are similar to English
and the word order is not a problem
I could go to finish so let's go and
look at there are others there's
Indonesian there's Tagalog there's a
bunch of languages and if you have
languages see the ones that have zero
Malay has zero Indonesian has zero
Gujarati has zero
uh Armenian Tagalog Hungarian has one
word that I saw these are you know
languages that I've played with but but
let's go into Finnish okay and we'll
have a look
so here we have finish
and I know it's the mini stories that I
want so I click on the first mini story
and I see this thing
okay so I can click on Mika that's my
name
and I by the way I do this all in
sentence mode sentence mode sentence
review is the best way to get started in
a language because you get a sense of
the language so you'll say no say no say
is Rises
is every
morning
six
okay so this is Mika gets up every
morning at six o'clock okay
now if I were doing this
in sentence review uh by the way I get
here by going from page view I'm now in
sentence view if I want to go back to
page view I click on page view but I
don't want to do that I want to stay in
sentence view now the next thing I can
do
is uh show translation High vocabulary
review sentence okay so now I gotta try
to remember no say no say no say no sir
Rises
okay
now
clock I think yeah
which every all right I got that right
now I got another
matching pairs here six was six
whoops six was good
Mika is
morning one thing about these matching
pairs is it's very easy to do
uh you I'll show you what happens if you
get the wrong but anyway now I've got to
reconstitute the sentence so I am going
to say Mika
uh uh no say
yoka
Amu
Kelo
coup d'etat but I forgot the a guy so I
gotta try to
he doesn't belong there
he belongs over here and I'm correct so
uh if I wanted to I could try and read
that Mikka no say Delta
if I start speaking it'll okay
so I got 34 that's okay
I'm not sure how meaningful that is so
then I would go to the next sentence and
I do the same
hen
is he she
prepares
da
um
yeah yeah and
you are
you're
drinks
kavya foreign
I can review the sentence again
so and and what I would do I don't need
to go through this necessarily the whole
way you owe his drinks yeah
prepare
whoops
well Mr
s hen and as you eliminate some then
it's easy to figure out what remains
coffee is easy so that's coffee
and is yeah some breakfast is
okay now I've got to
hen
um
yeah
okay so what that does give
and I can listen so initially I start
out with a language that is totally
means nothing to me and I can go through
sentence by sentence and I'll go and
I'll do sentence by sentence and of
course in these many stories the
sentence is in five parts so a lot of
vocabulary repeats so by the end of the
even One Mini story there are a lot of
yellow links that I've already looked up
so just for the fun of it
let us go
to uh
to see Bulgarian I wouldn't do because
it's so similar to the other Slavic
language is that it's too easy
um it's not fair
whereas I mean and some languages like
Armenian here
or Gujarati
uh the writing system is different so
it's extremely difficult for me to get
into but Indonesian
there the writing system is the same as
the Latin alphabet so I can open up the
same lesson and one of the advantages of
course
is that I know the stories because
they're the same in every story so show
translation oh so this is Story one this
is just the intro let's skip them
so here because I moved to the next page
the sentence repeats
um
in fact it's as if they were blue so
very cool very good very good following
Amy Amy this
Adela adala
is
story
ADI Adi
c c
the
cocky cook okay
we gotta work on the time stamping there
but
okay I can show the vocabulary
and then I can review the sentence so
it's the same idea uh see cookie I
remember that
charita
is
so I'm starting to get a sense very good
I remember they started with very quick
following
uh this is uh yeah it can't be Hardy
because
so the following is the story of Ari the
chef
but there's a obviously you got a
capital B here so this is the first word
in the sentence
um so Berita
very good any
jerita
now I'm stuck
I know see cookie verita
in a I can't remember you know I can't
remember so sorry so put ADI in there
adila see cookie that's wrong I don't
mind being wrong I submit very good any
Adela
okay so now I go to continue
and see what the sentence was I can say
start speaking
foreign
speaking I got 100 out of 100. okay no
big deal oops
now I I it used to be that the sentence
would show up again not the case let's
go back I wanted to see that sentence so
uh very good ini
is okay
this is so then I might just say this
this is
Adi
the cookie so by going through these
with the matching pairs the simple
stories by sentence
reconstituting the sentence I'm getting
kind of a grasp as an initial sense of
the language I have three months ahead
of me if I were to go into Finnish or
uh Indonesian where I would do these
many stories and then I I can show you
if I were studying it normally I would
go away and I'd be listening while doing
the dishes listening different places I
would do the lesson in in full page mode
and then again in sentence and after a
while by Dent of listening to these
stories over and over and over again
all of a sudden like right now if I were
to listen to the story without the
benefit of the text without the benefit
of the words that I've looked up
I wouldn't understand much but if I
continue doing this
in three months I will understand the 60
ministers that's a lot of content I am
then in the position to go for more
intermediate content content of more of
Greater interest which if we look at the
case of
Indonesian there's a whole bunch of
stuff there waiting for me Nasi Goreng
Indonesian food things that I can get
into later on but first I would begin
with the many stories and if I'm curious
about grammar I just go look it up on
Google or even ask chat GPT but mainly I
just want to get the language in me
whether it be Indonesian or
or Finnish or languages that are similar
to languages that I know which could be
Catalan which could be
Bulgarian which would be quite easy for
me because there's so much common
vocabulary and the structure is is not a
mystery as it is the K as is the case
here with these two languages so I just
thought I would do that to give you a
sense of what it might look like if I
were to embark on learning languages
from scratch and I look forward to your
comments thank you for listening bye for
now